our best to find the answers for people
we're on the banks of the cape fear
river in historic wilmington north
carolina
coming up we'll sit down with one
wilmington author who writes about the
u.s government-led effort to save
thousands of vietnamese children before
the fall of saigon in 1975
operation baby lift was an evacuation
of
two to three thousand vietnamese
displaced children
from saigon at the very end of the war
there in
april of 1975. the purpose of the baby
lift was to remove from vietnam
these several thousand displaced
children
who
were considered
orphans and therefore in need of stable
homes somewhere else and this was right
at the time when um the war in vietnam
which had lasted for 30 years it had
basically basically been going on since
1945 in different forms
was about to end so in march of 1975 the
north vietnamese began their their final
move into south vietnam and within six
weeks this 30-year war
really quickly came to an end and
there were a number of uh
small
and larger adoption
agencies in vietnam that were working
with children and preparing them for
adoption and these agencies decided at
that point when the north vietnamese was
about to take over that they needed to
expedite those adoptions and get the
children in their care out of vietnam as
quickly as possible and so with the help
of the us government they arranged an
airlift and they evacuated these
children the united states
left um
left vietnam or pulled out for the most
part in the early 1970s but it took a
while for
um it was the the
the war was still kind of at a stalemate
and so it wasn't until march of 1975
that the
that the north finally began to make the
moves that ended up
bringing the war to an end and that was
by
um moving south
starting in the central highlands and
then sort of slowly moving continuously
south
um from there and the south vietnamese
government made a really bad choice to
kind of pull back when the north began
this this final kind of invasion and
pull back and and try to fight in the
area where they felt most comfortable
and what happened was that caused a
panic and so people in the northern part
of south vietnam
felt that they had been abandoned by the
south vietnamese government and
they started fleeing farther south and
so you had you had um hundreds of
thousands of people
fleeing one part of the country and
moving south toward towards the
east and south so toward the coast and
then south towards saigon
and i guess the best way to describe
what was going on in that last six weeks
of the war was increasing chaos and
panic and a lot of south vietnamese
wanting to get out of the country as
well because they were afraid of what
was going to happen when the communists
took over
that point and um there was something
like
800 000
displaced children in vietnam
so
that's a really really large number and
that was a result to a large extent of
the war and by displaced i don't
necessarily mean that they were orphans
but that they were not able to be raised
by their parents
when it became clear that the south
vietnamese government was going to
collapse
the
adoption agency administrators in saigon
understood that this was going to be a
crisis for their agencies and for the
children that they were trying to send
for adoption overseas and many of these
children had been in the adoption
pipeline as they called it for months or
years already and they were just waiting
because adoption generally can take a
long time to process
so they became concerned that the
children who were in their care were not
going to end up being able to go
overseas because the government would
collapse and that they would have to
leave them in vietnam and they were
worried about their
what would happen to them and so they
began to
appeal to the u.s government to help
to
um
remove these children from the country
and it took a while and it took um there
was a there was um a man named ed daley
who ran a his own private airlines i
mean he
he was his airline was called world
airways and he he
brought in a lot of military equipment
into vietnam um so he made a lot of
money in vietnam but he also
had some concern about the children so
he ended up flying up the very first
plane load of children who left vietnam
on operation baby lift were actually
airlifted out on one of his planes i
mean it was you could say it was a big
publicity stunt you could say that he
was doing it because he um was really
concerned about these children for
whatever reason he airlifted the first
group and the us government seeing that
he had done this on his own and that it
was done in a way that was not
legally proper
decided to get involved and with that
gerald ford
decided to begin a more organized
evacuation
that was eventually called
operation baby lift or the orphan
airlift
uh the children who were being adopted
were for the most part going to the
united states although a significant
number went to europe and also australia
um
many if not most of them were already
scheduled to be adopted by families who
had been going through this process for
a while already
but in the end especially in the last
few weeks um i mean anybody who's seen
the photographs of the very end of the
war the fall of saigon and the the
helicopter on top of the u.s government
building
people climbing up to get in and just
the complete chaos at that time knows
that nothing worked in a really
organized and efficient manner and one
of the
results of that in terms of the baby
lift was that a lot of parents at the
very end of the war vietnamese parents
were so panicked about what was going to
happen to their children
after the communists took over that they
did whatever they could to get children
get their children into these adoption
agencies and on these planes to be
adopted overseas even if it meant giving
up those children and their ability to
care for them and so a lot of a lot of
the children
maybe
maybe
10 or 20 so not a majority but a
significant number um
sort of ended up on these planes at the
last minute and they were not already in
the adoption pipeline and then by the
time they got to the u.s um or the
countries that they ended up in there
was a question of where are we gonna how
how are we gonna place these peop these
children and where will we put them that
sort of thing first
u.s
sponsored plane that that was
uh
dedicated towards the baby lift was a
galaxy
aircraft which is a military aircraft
and it it came in to
vietnam on april 4th
and children were very quickly loaded
into the plane i think there were 200
and something children loaded onto a big
um cargo jet so i mean you know what the
inside of a passenger plane looks like
it's got
seats on it but this was a cargo jet so
most of it um the bottom part of it was
like the inside of a warehouse so
there's no seats there's there's no way
to sort of protect anybody that's on
there but it was it was such a
moment of chaos and and and concern
about what was going to happen that all
the children were just put onto the
plane very quickly so there were many
older children on the bottom of the
plane in this cargo area plus the
caregivers who got on with them and then
in the top part of the plane which is
kind of a passenger area there were a
lot of infants and nurses and people who
were taking care of the sickest children
so a few minutes after that plane took
off
the rear cargo door blew off
there was a big explosion
and
the pilots were able to maintain some
control over the plane they turned the
plane around
there's there are
testimonies from from people who were on
the top part of the plane who tell us
what happened what it was like inside
the plane um the fear that they felt
they were out over the water over the
ocean at that time the pilots were
incredible and they were able to turn
the plane around and try to get back to
saigon but they couldn't make it back to
saigon and the plane crashed in the rice
fields outside of saigon
we don't even know how many people were
killed because we don't know how many
people were actually on the plane as i
said everything was done in such a
disorganized rushed way
that and then a lot of the papers were
destroyed that it's hard to know there
were children who survived up above but
on the in the cargo area i think almost
everybody was killed
so that was um
it was like one heartbreak following so
many years of heartbreak already
and
so there was a question briefly about
whether or not the baby lift would
continue
but the president gerald ford said
we're going to keep going operation baby
lift lasted from
um for about three weeks
in maybe i should say a month in in
april of 1975 and when saigon fell
there were no more planes leaving
leaving vietnam with children in them so
it was a very short time in a very
intense time and during that period
something between two and three thousand
children were evacuated
following the baby lift
um and and the fall of saigon in the
months that the months after that
a group of lawyers filed a class action
lawsuit on behalf of these children
just to slow down the process of the
adoptions and make sure that all the
children who were being adopted were
legally eligible for adoption
um under the terms of the geneva accords
and um
that lawsuit was eventually thrown out
because um
more for legal reasons than on the
merits of the case because um the judge
decided that that these these children
didn't serve as a class which a
class-action lawsuit everybody has to
have suffered in the same way
anyway
there were individual lawsuits though
that that did go through and these were
mostly um
based on
birth parents who gave up their children
at the very end of the war mostly birth
mothers
and then they managed to get out of
vietnam themselves and get to the united
states as refugees and when they got to
the united states they looked for their
children and they when they found them
there were certain situations where the
adoptive families had had the children
for months or maybe even a year and the
birth parents filed to
regain custody of their children saying
that they had to give them up under
duress and those lawsuits played out and
a number of those there were there was
maybe less than 10 i think
those lawsuits generally ended with the
birth parents
receiving custody of their children
again but they were very complicated and
difficult for the most part adoptive
families ended up raising these children
i actually been doing research for a new
book on the refugee situation in
in europe and the middle east and it's
been very interesting to
be learning about that in the context of
what happened during operation baby lift
because there is very very little talk
about adoption now
the
the discussion of refugees focuses on
keeping families together
if there are orphans and there are
orphans unfortunately
there seem to be
real serious efforts to find them family
somewhere
a lot of times these families who are
fleeing
syria for example already have some
family members who are living in europe
and so a lot of times those orphans will
end up going to live with aunts and
uncles and cousins and grandparents
in countries in europe so i think that
i'm not saying that they're directly
thinking of operation baby lift when
they think about this policy but i think
that a lot has changed in the decades
since the baby lift and that
public policy makers and humanitarian
agencies and probably adoption agencies
as well are making an effort to really
do their homework and
not be pressed by chaos to rush into
anything even there was a um
there was an earthquake in haiti a few
years ago and there were some children
there
who were
in the process of being adopted by
american families and those children
because the situation in haiti was so
bad those children were airlifted out of
haiti and brought to i think
pennsylvania and
the adoption agency made some effort to
just expedite the adoption so that the
children could go into the families that
they were supposed to be adopted
um with
quicker
and the u.s government said no we are
not speeding up the process of adoption
just because of what happened there's
still things that need to be done to
make sure
that this is appropriate and i think
that's great
i want people who read this book
to understand that
these issues of what happens to
children and their families are really
complicated they are they can't be
solved easily
but that with time we can get there and
we need to do that for the children so
that we don't make mistakes that can't
really be remedied later
c-span where history unfold